pas encore assez petit
nous n'avons pas fini de vous laisser
dessus
Je suis maintenant à la loge qui devait
lancement
peu importe ce qui nous est arrivé
j'ai appris des choses
Eh bien, si je fais ça, nous
travailler ensemble
toi et moi alors toi donc nous vivons
sortent de la chose à quoi servent-ils
déplacer des choses, tout arrive
emballer
J'ai besoin de temps pour ne pas mourir
loge ne doit en aucun cas être suspecté
crée et ils le feront si vous
plus rien de lancement vient quand le
sont imprévisibles
tu le sais bien
les écoles sont très solidaires
embout d'acier
et les pauvres
c'est la liberté égalité pour beaucoup d'Allemands
fraternité ou mort
dirige depuis
oreilles
c'est bien que tu sois revenue elle
avoir des arguments convaincants sur celui-ci
moment l'éternité se bloque
mais attention quand la douzième étoile s'en va
sur le sort de
qui plaît à la chute dans le temps terrestre
seulement quand j'ai atteint le suivant
éternellement atteint son but pourquoi les connaître
Ruby appartient à son étoile pour l'éternité
flétrie ni affection tourmentée quand son
déclin être fragile alors peut
ce mec n'a pas de phrases simples et claires
de plutôt le type a au XVIIIe
siècle a vécu ainsi le douzième
l'étoile est s'il existe une chose telle que le compte
mais quel est ton but son étoile
brûlé ni amour tourmenté
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire le mal d'amour
refuser librement choisi tu es grand
tient qu'elle est un super-héros tu te lèves
le problème
cela pourrait vous mettre en danger
niveaux de prix dans le conseil